[Musik]
immer weiter wächst das blumenmeer am
musikpavillon einklappen
durch diesen park leafs herr grad bevor
sie am abend des dritten märz verschwand
der mord an der jungen frau deren leiche
am 10 märz gefunden wurde und für den
ausgerechnet ein polizist verantwortlich
zu sein scheint hat das gesamte land in
aufruhr versetzt anteilnahme und ärger
vermischen sich rebekka bakken und jody
sind in den letzten tagen immer wieder
hier gewesen wie so viele andere haben
die vier freundinnen das gefühl es hätte
jede von ihnen treffen können
sarah hat alles richtig gemacht sie hat
sportschuhe an hat helle kleider
getragen und ihrem freund bescheid
gesagt dass sie unterwegs war
aber eigentlich sollte ich doch auch
morgens um 1 durch den park laufen
können tragen können was auch immer ich
will
und trotzdem sicher sein es ist eine
riesen bewegung und überall in den
nachrichten und ich dachte dass es die
leute auf weckt aber in den letzten 48
stunden bin ich von vier
unterschiedlichen typen belästigt worden
wirklich unangenehm und man fragt sich
wann kapieren die es ein bild die
diskussion tatsächlich nicht nur in
großbritannien im netz teilen frauen
weltweit ihre bitteren erfahrungen mit
männlicher gewalt in london
demonstrierten sie zu tausenden in der
ganzen stadt
[Musik]
hier geht es um so viel mehr als den
mord an serra fast alle hier sind opfer
von belästigungen oder gar gewalt viele
haben das gefühl dass sie schon ewig
dasselbe sagen und dass nichts passiert
ich kann nicht fassen dass ich seit 35
jahren gegen genau dies alles auf die
straße gehe und es hat sich überhaupt
nichts bewegt seitdem ich ein teenager
war mir reicht's ich bin noch nie
irgendwo nachts entlang gelaufen ohne
meine schlüssel zu umklammern um mich
damit wären zu können
die angst geht nie weg und es wird nur
schlimmer dadurch dass ich jedes mal
beim joggen blöd angemacht werde
das ist inakzeptabel jamie klingler
engagiert sich seit 22 jahren
sie hat den hashtag reclaim the streets
geschaffen holt euch eure straßen zurück
wir werden man sagt uns das ist doch gar
nicht passiert bist du dir sicher gab es
zeugen wie betrunken warst du ich etwa
bin belästigt worden und es hat sehr
lange gedauert bis ich überhaupt
angehört wurde
jetzt wird uns mal zugehört es ist noch
mehr anders als sonst die wut die sich
gegen die polizei richtet etwa ein
polizist als täter und dann die
mahnwache für serra am samstagabend die
polizei versucht corvette abstandsregeln
durchzusetzen
es kommt zu handgreiflichkeiten und
festnahmen
vielen gilt das als weiterer beweis
dafür dass die sicherheitskräfte kein
verständnis für die belange von frauen
haben
nur 14 prozent aller vergewaltigungen in
großbritannien enden in der verurteilung
des täters
doch viele dieser verbrechen werden
überhaupt nicht angezeigt zu schmerzhaft
und zu aussichtslos scheinen den frauen
der gang vor gericht
schier endlose minuten dauerte es bis
die labour-abgeordnete jazz philips die
namen all der britinnen vorgelesen hatte
die im vergangenen jahr ermordet wurden
jeden dritten tag verliert eine frau ihr
leben häufig sind die täter der partner
oder ex-partner der premier hat
versprochen dass frauen von polizei und
justiz system besser unterstützt werden
sollen
50 millionen euro will er in der
straßenbeleuchtung und zivile
polizeikräfte stecken er kündigt nicht
nur härtere strafen für täter an
solange es in der gesellschaft keinen
wandel gibt er versteht dass frauen sich
momentan nicht gehört fühlen solange
werden wir dieses problem nicht lösen
können wir brauchen einen kulturellen
und sozialen wandel immer weniger fragen
sich was frauen für ihre sicherheit tun
können und immer mehr was männer ändern
müssen
[Musik]
wenn in einer pralinenschachtel einen
nicht gut schmeckt dann wenn man die
anderen auch nicht essen
wenn männer immer sagen das sind wir
doch nicht alle
ja das stimmt aber wie sollen wir wissen
welcher man in ordnung ist und welcher
nicht
neun von zehn männern wird wirklich
immer sagen dass es furchtbar ist was da
passiert ist
aber wenn ihre freunde abfällig über
frauen reden wenn sie gewalttätig werden
dann sind sie nur selten bereit ihnen zu
sagen dass das nicht okay ist
die bereitschaft genau darüber
nachzudenken ist ein weiterer aspekt
denn diesen moment in der geschichte des
feminismus einzig macht wirklich
überraschend und revolutionär ist dass
diese diskussion im ganzen land an den
abendbrottisch eingeführt wird
frauen sprechen mit ihren kleinen
kindern darüber söhne mit ihren vätern
die debatte hat sich in dieser woche
wirklich verändert die jungen frauen in
clapham hoffen darauf dass die bewegung
nicht abhebt dass sie eines tages alle
angst ablegen können
bis dahin aber gehen sie lieber
gemeinsam nach hause